continue place à notre grand débat
l'émission n'est pas terminé on la
portion va s'arrêter ce soir sur cette
décision de la cour de cassation dans la
sphère sarah halimi qui ne passe pas
l'arrêt du 14 avril entérine le
caractère antisémite du crime ait
confirmé l'impossibilité de traduire en
justice le meurtrier en cause son
discernement qui aurait été abolie par
la prise de stupéfiants
l'émotion est telle qu'un grand
rassemblement est organisé ce dimanche à
paris une plainte va être déposée en
israël et il est maintenant question de
changer la loi
en france faut-il aller jusque là on va
se poser la question avec nos invités
dans un instant d'avoir les explications
de marion delpech obtenir un procès
coûte que coûte contre le meurtrier de
sarah halimi jugé irresponsable
pénalement par la justice française
c'est le combat porté par sa soeur dont
les avocats ont annoncé hier l'intention
de saisir la justice israélienne
suite à l'arrêt consternant écartant
toute sanction pénale contre l'assassin
de sarah halimi je saisis avec francis
pinaire la justice israélienne d'une
plainte à l'encontre de kobe lee traoré
au nom des stères soeur de sarah et
citoyenne israélienne
la loi de ce pays étant compétente non
au déni de justice
la loi pénale d'israël peut s'appliquer
à des crimes antisémites commis à
l'étranger est dénoncé par un citoyen
israélien
l'arrêt de la cour de cassation a bien
entériné le caractère antisémite du
crime mais aussi confirmé
l'irresponsabilité de traduire en
justice le meurtrier
compte tenu de l' abolition de son
discernement lors des faits cette
décision suscite une très forte émotion
dans la communauté juive et bien au-delà
jusqu'au sommet de l'état
suite à l'appel dimanche dans le figaro
par emmanuel macron d'une modification
de la loi
le porte-parole du gouvernement a
défendu la volonté du président lundi
sur europe 1 est le sens de cette
décision ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui le
droit permet qu'une bouffée délirante
comme on dit
la consommation de stupéfiants entraîne
une irresponsabilité pénale c'est pas
possible
la drogue ça peut pas être un permis de
tuer plusieurs rassemblements à paris et
dans toute la france doivent avoir lieu
ce week end en l'honneur de la
sexagénaire juive défenestré en 2017
avec nous pour le grand débat d'elle bl
ce soir lydia guirous ce bienvenus vous
n'êtes pas essayiste et auteur de ce
livre assimilation en finir avec ce
tabou français jean pierre mignard est
également avec nous bien venu vous êtes
avocat au barreau de paris membre du
comité national d'éthique et maître de
conférences à sciences po avec nous à
distance morgan daury fauveau bienvenue
vous êtes professeur de droit privé
directrice de l'institut d'études
judiciaires damien et vous êtes l'auteur
d'une tribune publiée dans le figaro
affaires sarah halimi le risque de
récidive n'est pas illusoire
enfin philippe henry honegger bienvenue
vous êtes avocat pénaliste au barreau de
paris vous êtes co fondateur du cabinet
ruben et associés merci beaucoup à tous
les quatre d'être avec nous la ferme eu
beaucoup elle remue beaucoup l'opinion
le monde du droit le monde politique
jean pierre mignard est ce que vous la
partagez cette émotion est ce que vous
vous dites qu effectivement il ya
quelque chose qui n'a pas bien
fonctionné la partir du moment où il ya
une partie de l'opinion qui ne la
partage pas ça devient débat public donc
sur ce point question n'est même plus de
savoir si on la partage ou pas il ya une
question elle est là elle est posée donc
elle me semble légitime
oui d'ailleurs en ayant étudié les
textes c'est exact que c'était on peut
avoir un débat d'ailleurs ce soir
extrêmement académiques et très
difficile sur la question qui est celle
effectivement de la volonté de combattre
un acte et de la pleine connaissance de
cause de ce que l'on commet un acte
criminel un acte délictuel puisque quand
même dans notre droit l'intention de
commettre un délit ou un crime est un
des piliers de la constitution de
l'infraction pénale
alors est ce que l'on est toujours dans
quelles conditions et ont pleinement
conscience de la commission d'une
infraction et jusqu'où la société
peut-elle réclamer des comptes à celui
ou celle qui a commis une infraction
est-ce qu'ils avaient connaissance de ce
qu'il faisait ce qu'il avait conscience
est-ce qu'il s'était mis en situation de
ne pas savoir ce qu'il allait commettre
et dans ces conditions
cela at il un sens de l'eau ou de la
condamner puisque n'oublions pas que le
deuxième pilier ra3 la réinsertion de la
personne dans la peine et l'imputabilité
d'une part et ensuite effectivement la
peine prononcée en appel doit être
exemplaire
quelques exemplaires pour la personne
est exemplaire pour bordeaux pour
qu'elles soient exemplaires déjà pour la
personne concernée faut-il qu'elles
aient conscience de ce qu'elle est
méritée ses peines et puis faut-il aussi
que à l'extérieur on en ait conscience
aussi c'est très compliqué dans la
sphère de madame sarah l'aimé et ainsi
rentrer dans le détail
didier gay rose elle vous a ému vous
cette affaire et cette décision de la
cour de cassation bien sûr qu'elle m'a
ému rappelons quand même qu'il s'agit
d'une femme qui a été torturé je crois
que tous les autres son visage ont été
brisées et qui a été ensuite défénestré
donc on pouvait quand même s'attendre
avec avec cet homme qui a crié ils me
semble-t-il à la barre donc on pouvait
quand même s'attendre à ce que cette
décision ait une portée dans l'ensemble
de la société et aurait fallu quand même
qu'il soit condamné et moi je suis très
gêné face à cette décision parce que je
me dise il suffit de fumer un joint pour
être reconnu comme comme comme
irresponsable et échapper à une peine de
prison ce qui ne permet pas à la famille
de faire son deuil parce qu'aujourd'hui
ne peuvent pas faire leur deuil dans ces
conditions évidemment que j'ai été
extrêmement ému et j'espère que
l'ensemble de la communauté nationale
est ému ça ne concerne pas que la
communauté juive je veux quand même le
souligner parce que j'ai entendu
quelques responsables politiques de dire
que c'est l émotion qu uniquement pour
la communauté juive à julien bayou
membre de la réussite et voilà julien
bayou pour ne pas le citer mais c'est je
dirais que c'est assez attendu de la
part d' europe ecologie les verts et je
voudrais juste rappeler que je pense que
c'était à brest cinq mois de prison pour
une personne qui avait jeté un chien par
par la fenêtre
il ya eu six mois de prison
châteaudun pour une personne qui avait
jeté également un chien par la fenêtre
donc quand on pense à ces deux décisions
évidemment ça n'a rien à voir mais quand
même on se dit est ce que la vie d'une
femme je vaux mieux que vos mois que la
vie d'un chien évidemment que ça suscite
l'émotion mais asus temps il est
scandalisé en fait par cette décision
qui a forcément une portée dans la
société qui envoie un très mauvais
message
parce qu'on a un antisémitisme notamment
le nouvel antisémitisme liés à la montée
de l'islam radical qui est présent qu'il
faut combattre tous les jours et ces
décisions n'aide pas le combattre morgan
daury fauveau qu'elles peuvent être
effectivement les conséquences d'une
telle décision que faut-il craindre ce
qu'on peut craindre évidemment c'est
l'interprétation qu'on en fait là sur ce
plateau ce serait voilà d'aboutir à
cette incohérence absolue qui consiste à
pouvoir bénéficier d'une
irresponsabilité pénale
lorsque 11 c'est vraiment très gravement
intoxiqué volontairement c'est
évidemment la crainte que l'on peut
nourrir et qui est d'autant plus
regrettable
on aurait pu attendre de la chambre
criminelle qu'elle prenne une autre
décision fondée sur l'article 122-1 et
qu'elle parvienne à la solution
exactement inverse qui aurait consisté à
retenir la responsabilité pénale de
traoré philippe henry honegger et ce
n'est pas une erreur de la cour de
cassation qui ne se prononce pas sur le
fond on est bien d'accord elle la cour
de cassation a fait avec les textes
existants oui alors il pour répondre à
votre question sur l'émotion l'émotion
face à ces faits qui sont terrifiants
elle est absolument légitime
c'est-à-dire qu'on ne peut pas être ému
face à ça et on ne peut pas faire autre
chose que d'attendre une réponse du
système judiciaire face à ces faits là
et si l'émotion est légitime
la réponse juridique qui a été apportée
par la cour de cassation et elle
absolument légitime aussi il faut bien
comprendre une chose
le débat est la question à laquelle a
répondu la cour de cassation n'est pas
de savoir si jamais comme on vous l'a
dit à l'instant j'ai pris des produits
stupéfiants
je vais pouvoir me prévaloir de l'état
dans lequel je me suis mis moi même
pour faire valoir une responsabilité
pénale c'est pas ça la question
parce que si je me mets dans un état à
cause des produits stupéfiants et que je
commets des infractions la réponse de la
loi est extrêmement clair la réponse de
la cour de cassation est extrêmement
clair vous êtes responsable pénalement
d'accord ça c'est clair a pas de débat
sur cette question l'avenir caricature
et j'ai entendu vous avez passé monsieur
à table tout à l'heure tu disais une
bouffée délirante liés à la consommation
de produits stupéfiants pourrait
conduire à l'irresponsabilité pénale
la réponse est non jamais c'est pas
possible en droit
d'accord ça c'est clair le débat s'est
pas celui-là le débat qui a été posée
c'est de dire en revanche si on est
quelqu'un qui a une abolition de son
discernement pour des raisons
psychiatriques ou psychique qui ne sont
pas liées directement aux produits
stupéfiants
dans ces cas là on est irresponsable
pénalement
et cette question là elle est tranchée
aussi en droit et elle est irrévocable
la question qui a été posée à la cour de
cassation n'était pas de savoir si on
était dans un cas dans l'autre la
question m'a été posée en réalité au
fond c'est à dire une question de fait à
des experts et les experts ont dit de
manière très claire ils étaient
plusieurs que l'état dans lequel se
trouvait ce monsieur n'était pas lié
directement à la prise de stupéfiants
métailié un état psychiatrique antérieur
et d'ailleurs ce monsieur depuis qu'il a
été mis sous soins est sous surveillance
psychiatrique
il a fait d'autres bouffée délirante qui
ne sont pas liées non plus à la prise de
stupéfiants puisqu'il n'en a pas pris
dans le cadre des soins si tu as pris la
parole philippe aurait un égal parce que
ce que vous dites fait réagir et je
voudrais juste entendre la réaction de
morgane daury fauveau qui fait non de la
tête alors peut-être entendre son point
de vue je suis pas d'accord avec ce qui
vient d'être ni pour la raison suivante
en fait tâche c'est que l'abolition du
discernement donc le trouble psychique
ou neuropsychique entraîne
l'irresponsabilité pénale lorsque ce
trouble psychique ou neuropsychique est
la cause directe et exclusive du passage
à l'acte en or ici qu'est ce que l'on
constate c'est que le trouble psychique
ou neuropsychique ça débouchait
délirante n'a pas aidé la cause
exclusive du passage à l'acte monsieur
traoré avait apparemment
d'autres mobiles h par ailleurs deuxième
chose c'est que dans les trois rapports
d'experts j'ai dit très clairement les
trois constate l'existence d'une bouffée
délirante
il y en a qu'un seul des trois rapports
d'experts qui y voient un épisode
inaugural de schizophrénie les deux
autres rapports et en particulier le
premier qui a été rendu par monsieur à
nous y voilà qui est un expert
extrêmement reconnu dit dit très
clairement que traoré n'est pas atteint
d'une maladie mentale qui laurent non
discernant en tout cas donc si les fils
à comines
il a commis un acte très grave il a
effectivement eu une bouffée délirante
qui est là des lames et mobile du
passage à l'acte des explications mais
pas la seule du passage à l'acte n'a pas
de maladie mentale une choix qui sera ce
vrai qu'il faut être clair il n'y aura
plus de raison de le retenir en hôpital
psychiatrique et une fois qu'il sera so
les gentils on ne retient conséquent que
ce que ce que vous dites est juste parce
que en fait on est dans une situation
qui est plus complexe néanmoins parce
que il ya à l'évidence un terrain qui
est un terrain psychiatrique
je pense qu'il n'est pas contestable
donc ce terrain psy karité qui aurait
fait l'objet d'une expertise ou
plusieurs expertises qui aurait amené en
effet la cour d'assises peut être à
retenir une circonstance atténuante une
part des responsabilités liées à un
terrain psychiatrique ça c'est
incontestable deuxième chose il y a sans
doute l'absorption de stupéfiants ce qui
veut dire que c'est le cumul des deux
qui effectivement entraîne ce passage à
l'acte est un crime alors là c'est un
crime antisémite à je veux dire oui ça y
est c'est très important parce que si
vous voulez moi ce qui me mène
m'intrigue dans ce dossier si répond on
ça se termine par une abolition du
discernement mais néanmoins reconnaît
que c'est un crime ce qui était le cas
c'est un crime antisémite aucun paradoxe
mais oui je vais c'est vrai que je
trouve que je le dis comme je le pense
je suis pas arrivé à
à dépasser cet obstacle mais je trouve
en effet qu il me semble qu'ils ont un
paradoxe est que je trouve
personnellement qu'on est plus dans le
domaine de l'altération du discernement
qu'on est dans le domaine de la alors
merci c'est la famille en tout cas pose
une question c'est faut-il changer la
loi oui ou non emmanuel macron a tranché
il a dit oui il l'a fait savoir dans le
figaro cette semaine ça n'a échappé à
personne et il demande même au garde des
sceaux de le faire au plus vite
vous imaginez qu eric dupond moretti a
bien reçu le message il l'a exprimé hier
et côté je suis totalement contre l'idée
que l'on puisse juger des fous enfin
c'est ce que l'on faisait au moyen-âge
peuvent les fous il faut les soigner
monsieur sport touchant mais pour autant
la question ont droit qui est posée c
est un homme qui a consommé une les
psychotropes à raison de cela peut être
considéré comme irresponsable et lydia
guirous faut-il changer la loi
bien sûr qu'il faut changer la loi parce
que c'est enfin aujourd'hui peut-être
que cette décision a dit le droit mais
elle n'a pas rendu la justice et il faut
faire évoluer le droit parce que ça ne
doit plus jamais on ne doit plus jamais
se retrouver dans de telles situations
avec de telles décisions
je ne crois pas que toutes les personnes
qui soit 6,4 icm en déséquilibre est fou
et et on vit après avoir fumé un joint
d'aller tuer une femme de 60 ans de la
torture et de la défénestré je ne pense
pas que ce soit le cas et donc je ne
comprends pas dans cette décision
comment on a pu en arriver à dire qu'en
fait il était totalement irresponsable
et qui est en fait il va aller à
l'hôpital psychiatrique et ensuite dans
deux ans il va en sortir et peut-être
qu'il croisera des membres de la famille
de madame halimi puisqu'il ya eu
d'autres cas où ça c'est où ça s'est
produit donc il faut absolument que les
parlementaires se mobilisent et fasse un
véritable travail pour qu'on puisse
faire évoluer le droit c'est l'heure
c'est lors c'est leur responsabilité
parce qu'on ne doit plus se retrouver
dans cette situation qui envoie quand
même un message qui est juste désastreux
j'ai bien vu que wim néanmoins vous
trouver dans une situation particulière
madame giroux c'est à dire que vous avez
un cumul
vous avez un cumul d'un terrain
psychiatrique et en plus d'absorption
méfiants alors je pense en effet que le
deuxième acte qui est l'absorption me
semble pas devoir être tenue
comme étant une circonstance de nature à
réduire la responsabilité pénale
d'accord quand on conduit un véhicule et
qu'il ya une absorption d'alcool on
n'est pas pour autant même ces mêmes
enfin mais ça mais il ya de toute façon
le terrain je pense que dans le cas
dramatique de madame halimi c'est qu'on
est dans un cumul qui pouvait entraîner
et fanny vend une réunion de la cour
d'assises qui pourrait statuer sur une
altération seulement une altération un
teint et non pas une abolition du
discernement face et font sentir hors du
cac le débat me semble très sérieux on
va les gars cette loi ou pas peut pas
l'évacuer mais encore une fois on a tout
un débat sur des éléments de fait et pas
sur des éléments de droit c'est à dire
que c'est parce qu'ils disent des
experts
la phrase du président la république
c'est de dire la loi actuelle ne
distingue pas l'origine du trouble
psychiatrique conduisant à l'abolition
et moi je vous dis et la cour de
cassation dit la loi actuelle donne une
distinction
concernant l'origine du trouble
psychiatrique si c'est des stupéfiants
c'est une aggravation de la peine si
c'est pas liée directement à des
stupéfiants c'est une responsabilité
donc moi je veux bien qu'on change la
loi on va la changer comment parce que
si c'est pour changer la loi en disant
que les gens pourraient ainsi patrick
antérieur et qui font des bouffées
délirantes
en raison de cela doivent être
responsables pénalement et doivent être
condamnés par la cour d'assises à ce
moment là c'est remettre en cause l'idée
assez simple qui est de dire on ne juge
pas les fous et je vais vous dire
pourquoi est-ce qu'on en juge pas les
fous parce que ce monsieur qu'est
aujourd'hui avec des soins
psychiatriques et qui continue à faire
des bouffées délirantes
comment vous l'aller devant une cour
d'assises comment vous faites pendant
cinq jours pour amener quelqu'un qui ne
comprend pas de quoi on lui parle qui
peut-être ne se souvient pas de ce qui
s'est passé qui vous apportera aucun
élément ni avant ni après et qui en
détention sera un bon j'ai un danger
pour lui-même et un danger pour les
autres c'est pour ça qu'on ne juge pas
les fous
c'est pour ça qu'on l'aimé dans ces deux
hôpitaux psychiatriques est d'ailleurs
question de la définition du fou qu'est
ce que vous mettez derrière
c'est beau c'est ici qu'un trouble si
stéphanie c'est quelqu'un qui a des
troubles en l'occurrence c'est quelqu'un
qui a des troubles psychiatriques qui ne
sont pas liées directement la prise de
stupéfiants
est ce que les experts en 10 mois je
suis pas expert je connais pas le
dossier je suis pas rentré j'ai pas vu
ce monsieur j'ai pas fait des études de
psychiatrie est ce qu'on dit les experts
c'est que ce monsieur il avait un
terrain antérieur quand il peut amener à
avoir des problèmes psychiatriques que
c'est ça on réclame causé la bouche et
délirante et les actes qu'il a commis
des si dans ce cas là on parle d'actes
antisémites est en même tant
d'irresponsabilité pénale c'est parce
que monsieur sarkozy à l'époque où il
était président a fait passer une loi
qui permet maintenant à la chambre de
l'instruction
au rang des 10 des décisions et c'est
vrai qu'elle sent paradoxale dans
laquelle on dit à la fois
ce monsieur est auteur d'un cri pas
antisémite on peut dire ça ce qu'on ne
disait pas avant mais en même temps il
ya une ordonnance d' irresponsabilité
pénale et donc on prend des mesures de
sûreté précise que pour sûr me suivre
des mesures de sûreté qui ont été prises
à hauteur de 20 ans ça veut dire que ce
monsieur pendant vingt ans il va être
suivie par la justice et par la
psychiatrie pour s'assurer qu'il est
soigné qui recommence pas ça me semble
la balle dans un instant jean pierre
mignard mais morgane dort il faut vous
rêvez réagir aussi oui alors vont encore
encore une fois c'est pas ce que disent
les rapports d'expertisé en tout cas pas
les trois rapports d'expertisé et s'est
traîné pendant l'arrêt de la chambre de
l'instruction qui avait été rendue en
2019 et dans l'arrêt de la chambre de la
chambre criminelle d'une part par
ailleurs sur le changement même de la
loi
j'ai moi je n'y suis pas favorable en
fait si vous voulez soyons très clairs
c'est cette décision de la cour de
cassation qui me parlait critiquable ça
n'est pas la loi en elle-même la cour de
cassation sur le fondement du même texte
pouvait parvenir à la solution
exactement inverse c'est ça n'est pas le
texte qui est en cause c'est
l'interprétation qui en est faite
encore une fois la le
l'absence de discernement ne peut être
constatée est donc la cause
d'irresponsabilité pénale ne peut être
retenu que lorsque le trouble psychique
ou neuropsychique est la cause directe
et exclusive du passage à l'acte
or ce n'est pas le cas dans cette
affaire imaginez un mari extrêmement
jaloux de son épouse qui la journée
durant boit des litres et des litres
d'alcool en se remontant tout seul sur
la soi-disant sur le soi-disant adultère
de son épouse
le voilà le soir en état de delirium
tremens sa femme arrive il a dû mais
vous allez dire que le delirium tremens
est véritablement la seule cause du
passage à l'acte est donc que cet homme
doit cat est responsable pénalement pas
du tout pas du tout il faut que ce soit
la cause exclusive corse à nos idées on
doit retenir la responsabilité pénale et
il n'est nul besoin de changer l'article
122-1 du code pénal sont terminés
oui je trouvais 6 et pour que tout est
spectacle comprend bien que parlons là
d'un crime antisémite
notre raisonnement vaut pour des crimes
de géant pour des féministes et des
crimes racistes qu'elle a conservé un
monde où la sambre ce qui est
intéressant
un expert parlait de de quelqu'un qui
avait beaucoup sur l'antisémitisme
participer mais sans de démonologie
donc je serai un terrain psychiatriques
tels que bon très bien à mettons cela
mais moi je suis d'accord avec ce que
vous dites mais un professeur c'est à
dire que ceux qui le passage à l'acte se
fait par un cumul
or dans le cul il ya peut-être un
terrain sur lequel en effet il ne peut
rien et contre lequel on ne peut pas lui
demander de responsabilité mais sur le
reste
sur l'absorption de stupéfiants je suis
désolé il n'y a pas de raison qu'il y
ait de faire un traitement a pas pour ce
qui est par exemple de l'alcool ou ski
et les stupéfiants dans ce cas là on
serait plus dans l'altération cela dit
nos confrères pour une dernière question
que je trouve lui intéressante et
comment s'opère
un procès dans ces conditions là avec
une personne je sais pas du tout comment
elle pourrait se comporter à l'audience
est là je n'en vois mal à me dire où ça
se comprend bien la position mais pour
que ce soit exemplaire
faut-il encore que ce soit
compréhensible par lui etc
mais je pense que ce n'est qu'une
altération alors on a leur abolition en
attendant les parlementaires ont
commencé à travailler ils se sont saisis
de la question vous parliez vous même
d'une réécriture de la loi par les
parlementaires il ya le député lr
guillaume larrivé qui a déposé une
proposition de loi en début de semaine à
l'article 122-1 du code pénal qui
définit donc les responsabilités pénales
il propose de rajouter à la fin du
premier rallye annie l'alinéa stipulant
que n'est pas pénalement responsable la
personne qui était atteinte au moment
des faits d'un trouble psychique ou
neuropsychique ayant aboli son
discernement ou le contrôle de ses actes
les mots sauf si ce trouble résulte de
la consommation de produits stupéfiants
ou d'alcool et au sénat ça fait un petit
bout de temps qu'on a travaillé sur le
sujet qu'on s'est saisie de ce sujet
trois propositions de loi ont été
déposées en un an
l'une d'entre elles a été déposé par la
sénatrice centriste nathalie goulet
elle va d'ailleurs être examinée on l'a
appris tout à l'heure elle va être
examiné le 25 mai prochain
nathalie goulet qui a été interrogée par
steve jourdain au sujet de cette affaire
cette semaine écoutez cette proposition
vise à exclure les dispositifs le
dispositif de l'article l 122 1 aux
personnes qui se seraient mieux
volontairement dans une situation d'
irresponsabilité
si vous comparez le régime par exemple
aux gens qui conduisent en état
d'ivresse ou sous l'emprise de
stupéfiants leurs responsabilités
accrues
donc si quelqu'un prend des stupéfiants
il n'y a absolument aucune raison que il
il s'auto en quelque sorte excuses
philippe henry en égard je vous vois
lever les yeux au ciel ça vous paraît
dément de réécrire la loi de rajouter ça
mais en fait si vous voulez ces gens qui
font des propositions en fait ne connaît
rien au droit c'est à dire que la phrase
qui vient de rajouter n'ajoute
strictement rien au droit existant
aujourd'hui l'état du droit tel qu'il
est appliqué par la cour de cassation
c'est que votre trouble s'il est
directement liée à la prise de
stupéfiants ou la prise d'alcool ne
pourra pas être considéré comme une
responsabilité pénale
l'exemple qui vous a été donné tout à
l'heure de dire un homme qui ploie
coutal peu l'équipe a tué sa femme
pendant tout l'état dans tous les cas il
sera considéré responsable pénalement ça
n'existe pas de situation en france
dans un cas comme celui-là on a
considéré qu'une personne était
irresponsable
on vient rajouter à cette fois ça ne
rajoute rien c'est un peu changé bien et
je peux même vous dire que si demain
l'état du droit et celui qui serait le
résultat de cette modification
la cour de cassation au regard des
expertises qui ont été rendues dans ce
dossier rendrait exactement la même
politique et rose moi je fais confiance
aux parlementaires comme notamment à
guillaume larrivé qui ont été très bien
le droit prestation on vous a entendu de
loi philippe bardet gaza vers des
rochers
on peut se dire conscient oui bien sûr
le manthey sont pas les juristes
d'attentes à l'anglaisé ci n'est pas
bien vite à réviser un petit peu sa
biographie donc je vais chercher
confiance à guillaume larrivé qui
connaît très bien le droit et qui est je
crois qu'il faut le faire évoluer parce
qu'on peut plus se retrouver dans des
situations pareilles
moi je ne suis pas une experte du droit
mais une chose est sûre c'est que c'est
c'est juste insoutenable et je crois
qu'on peut pas se retrouver dans des
situations où la justice n'est pas
rendue il ya une émotion qui est très
forte en france
ça fait plusieurs décisions de justice
où on est juste on reste sans voix en se
disant mais quel est le message qui est
envoyé à l'ensemble de la société lyons
le risque effectivement c'est que les
politiques s'emparent de sujets noirs
hérités d'une émotion d'une froment part
est-ce que c'est toujours le bon moment
de changer les lois parce qu'il est en
mission poney là c'est un sujet met
alors à lequel à quel moment
on le change en fait si on croit quand
on a pas mais oui mais vous savez vous
savez je pense que c'est pas la première
affaire en fait de d'homicide avec un
caractère antisémite ou il fallait il a
fallu parfois se battre quand même pour
que le caractère antisémites soient
reconnues soient reconnus moi je me
souviens aussi de muriel mireille knoll
7 cet octogénaire qui avait été
assassiné il ya une grande mobilisation
et a fallu vraiment une bataille et et
avoir vraiment beaucoup de médiatisation
pour que ce soit reconnue donc il ya un
moment se demande aussi pourquoi on a
autant de difficultés à reconnaître le
caractère antisémite de certains
homicides et je crois qu'il faut le
saisir aussi quand c'est dans l'émotion
nationale quand c'est dans ce moment là
parce que c'est dans ce moment là où on
peut faire évoluer les mentalités et sur
la question de l'antisémitisme il faut
faire évoluer les mentalités il ya un
grand risque dans notre pays et je suis
franchement je suis meurtri de savoir
que les avocats de sarah halimi vont
devoir aller en israël au nom de la
soeur de sarah halimi pour que le pro
pour essayer d'avoir un procès et pour
que la justice soit rendue l'altra
symbole hiver juste refusé
symboliquement symbolique un résident
les traditions bien sûr mais mais c'est
quand même un échec pour pour notre pays
et c'est un message qui est désastreux
qui a renvoyé à l'ensemble de
reconnaître quand même que la la nature
du crime antisémite est très clairement
énoncés elle n'a jamais été cachés
d'ailleurs on pourrait imaginer même
qu'une cour d'assises composée
uniquement les trois magistrats
solennellement lise l'arrêt de la
chambre d'instruction qui effectivement
considère que y'a pas d'imputabilité
possible ça c'est la première chose
deuxième chose bon allé en israël très
bien mais c'est vous savez je suis pas
sûr que ça résoudre ça va rien résoudre
ça va pas faire avancer notre droit je
veux dire peut-être d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs on faisait face à pléguien
polémique non mais on sait pas du tout
ce que vont décider les juges israélien
parce que je ne connais pas le droit
pénal israélien je ne sais pas du tout
ce qu'il nie sur ce point on d'israël
mais il ya du juste rapide droit israël
tapei droit et juste
juridiction pas du tout convaincu que
sur ce point on n'est pas des surprises
en tout cas pour ceux qui saisissent
donc je crois que et enfin troisièmement
une loi mais je suis assez d'accord avec
ce que dit le professeur une
modification de la loi la chambre
criminelle de la cour de cassation a les
éléments pour effectivement faire
avancer sa jurisprudence
en tant que nécessaire elle est déjà
loin quand je lis le rapport par exemple
de série quand je lis les réquisitions
de l'avocat général
c'est ça va extrêmement loin c'est très
fouillé ses prêts poussé la chambre
criminelle de la cour de cassation peut
aller plus loin encore pour dissocier ce
qui retient relève de l'abolition du
discernement de l'altération parce que
c'est là que se jouent les choses je
suis juste pour faire réagir par don
morgan daury fauveau sur ce changement
de loi cette modification de la loi qui
arrive puisqu'on apprend que le sénat va
en et va examiner une proposition de loi
le 25 mai vous êtes vous dit que ça va
trop vite c'est pas le bon moment où
sont pas les bons mots non c'est pas que
je sois pour ou contre
que ce soit le moment non pas le moment
je tombe je trouve ça regrettable parce
que c'était inutile en réalité encore
une fois c'est inutile parce que la cour
de cassation pouvaient absolument
aboutir à une autre décision
moi j'invite vraiment le le monsieur qui
est intervenu l'avocat qui est
intervenue par visio j'invite à lire
l'arrêt de la chambre de l'instruction
et à lire l'arrêt de la cour de
cassation parce que ben oui mais lydie
comme lé noir sur blanc que l'article
122-1 ne distingue pas selon l'origine
du trouble donc nous assure blanc elle
le dit ou fait délirante et encore une
fois ça mais par miss mais c'est quand
même incroyable
il faut relire les attendus ils sont
interdits
le cannabis n'est pas à cause ils sont
quand même extrêmement clair j'ai l'air
ch il ya un seul des trois rapports
d'experts qui voit dans la bouche et
délirante un épisode inaugural de
schizophrénie les deux autres rapports
d'experts disent clairement que la
bouffée délirante est due à la
consommation de stupéfiants
15 juin par jour depuis une quinzaine
d'années donc c'est quand même
extrêmement clair et c'est écrit noir
sur blanc dans les deux arrivent non
encore une fois il suffisait de
d'appliquer cette condition en fait de
la cause des responsabilités liées au
caractère exclusif direct et exclusif du
lien de causalité entre le trouble
psychique ou neuropsychique et le
passage à la tâche ici tel n'était pas
le cas
traoré aurait dû être tenu responsable
pénalement
parce que l'état dans lequel il était
n'était pas la cause directe et
exclusive du passage à l'acte
oui je partage est juste te dire qu'en
fait cette cette décision comme celle de
viry-châtillon ou dans les conclusions
on a parlé de chance pour la france
je vais terminer monsieur je vous
remercie donc ou dans les conclusions on
a indiqué dans l'ordre dans les
conclusions ils ont quand même indiqué
que c'était des chances pour la france
ces personnes qui ont essayé de tuer en
brûlant des policiers je trouve que ça
envoie un message qui est juste
désastreux et qui va faire que renforcer
ceux qui ont un sentiment d'impunité qui
pensent qu'ils sont intouchables donc
s'il faut faire évoluer le droit pour
que justice soit rendue et bien faisons
évoluer le droit alors il nous reste 30
secondes philippe oriane égard je vous
laisserai bon mais très rapidement mais
c'est ce qui se passe avec l' affaire
halimi la sphère lundi rich attention
c'est exactement le même phénomène moi
j'étais au procès de viry châtillon et
mon client a été acquitté voyez vous et
donc ce qui est dit dans les médias
c'est n'importe quoi
la seule chose dont on peut se réjouir
c'est que des innocents et été innocenté
et la seule chose dont on peut ça triste
et c'est qu'on n'ait pas trouvé les
véritables coupes
abl en raison d'une enquête policière
qui était lacunaire et qui était vissée
venir remettre en cause des décisions de
justice auquel on n'a pas participé dans
des affaires qu'on ne connaît pas mal
rarissime et c'était en réaction au sens
de la loi et problème c'était la déprime
et l'émotion sur le droit et c'est très
dangereux et ce qui est dit dans les
médias n'est pas n'importe quoi c'est au
travers de la loi d'intervenants comme
vous tous et on donne la parole à tout
le monde
merci merci en tout cas à tous les
quatre d'avoir participé à ce débat
c'est la fin de cette émission on se
retrouve lundi à 18 heures et à 22
heures demain bonjour chez vous dès 7h30
alexandre poussa recevra notamment
philippe martinez secrétaire général de
la cgt je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée sur public sénat